[Música]
días antes de que mi padre muriera
recuerdo mirarlo fijamente a los ojos
tenía los ojos cafés con un halo
grisácea alrededor del iris y decirme a
mí misma nunca olvides a sus ojos
después de su muerte la realidad no
hacía sentido tenía que entender la vida
y la muerte
quizás por mi formación como
cinefotógrafo
instintivamente así como cuando nos da
hambre sentir la necesidad de mirar sus
cenizas al microscopio
para sorpresa de todos los científicos a
los que me acerqué que auguraron
imágenes monocromáticas el
descubrimiento que hice transformó mi
visión del mundo
el universo entero entro en mi mente
era como estar flotando en el universo
para conocer ese espacio un espacio
expansivo sin cuerpo
era contento absoluto se volvió paz
esta imagen
la ven
esa es la imagen de las cenizas de mi
padre al microscopio
y esta otra es la del hermano de alguien
más y así podría enseñarles infinitas
todo mi miedo y toda mi tristeza
desaparecieron no sentí desconexión de
nada ni de nadie
su muerte más que un fin representó el
principio doble que hoy es el proyecto
de mi vida de tesón project
para mí esto insinúa que nuestra más
pura esencia material somos acariciados
por el cosmos
y que cuando nos miramos al espejo hay
quizá en ese reflejo infinitamente más
de lo que creemos
y que la materia no se cree ni se
destruya se vuelve más una acción
adivino que un principio de
termodinámica gracias
[Aplausos]